win two more games than this
nightmare of a match which it has become
will be over
i'm sticking to the scandinavian i made
the is that i'm only going to play this
candidate
i made a promise to myself that is
okay let me try bishop f5 instead now
now i gotta go queen b4
try and bother him a [ __ ]
and the camera froze
okay
refresh
does he have some kind of d5 here
i don't know i'm not
massively worried about it
yeah he was probably thinking about
[Music]
castles and then d5s are i want to
be prepared for that
f4 queen of five what's this point you
can't go c3
this rook is hanging
b3 i just castle one laugh
is misplaced right
yeah so this is probably his most
sensible route yeah
this one
i feel like with bishop d6 he takes b4
and if
i move the 90s knight c5 so i want to
keep it a bit more complicated
okay this makes a lot of sense p5
minus six
and c5 i'm definitely better though
this there is no doubt about
the question is how much and
considering how misplaced some of these
pieces are i would say
quite a bit better
so i can take a pawn cd 94 bishop a3
question is if i want something more
i should probably do
it just push b4 actually getting rid of
that
bishop probably just massively
overthinking this but
it feels like there's some point to it
so cd is quite something
knight d4 knight c3
rook d3 hmm
okay i better go push those sticks first
then
push b3 yeah it's time to go c4
maybe cd was possible there which would
define my g5
okay trying to
surf gravel
make some sort of sad draw here but
and then just fight me that's the point
that's what he wants to do
to the defensive position and flag me
[Music]
well
yeah now i'm going to hustle mode
takes it through don't think he saw that
i'm at the very least open up
probably shouldn't have allowed
this one though
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
i'd love to be in a bit of a better mood
but
my play is so bad